vamos a pensar en otro escenario que
involucra razones en este caso queremos
la razón del número de manzanas el
número de manzanas en relación con el
número de frutas que tenemos aquí el
número de frutas y los invito a pasar el
vídeo y a pensar en la respuesta por
ustedes mismos
bueno cuál es el total de manzanas que
tenemos 2 468 tenemos 8 manzanas y cuál
es el total de frutas que tenemos ya
vimos que tenemos 8 manzanas y tenemos 3
6 9 12 naranjas en total de frutas es 8
+ 12 que es igual a 20 piezas de fruta
así que la razón será 8 a 20 8 a 20 o si
queremos escribir esto de una manera
reducida podemos dividir estos dos
números entre 44 es el máximo común
divisor y esta razón es lo mismo que 8
dividido entre 4 es igual a 2 y 20
dividido entre
es igual a 5 así que tenemos 25 y esto
tiene sentido si dividimos todo en
cuatro grupos y lo voy a hacer aquí un
grupo
dos grupos
tres grupos
y cuatro grupos es el mayor número de
grupos en los que podemos dividir estas
frutas sin tener que cortar las manzanas
o las naranjas vemos en cada grupo que
por cada dos manzanas tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro o cinco piezas de fruta por
cada dos manzanas tenemos cinco piezas
de fruta y esta es una buena oportunidad
para introducir otra manera de
representar razones y es usando la
notación de fracciones así que también
podemos representar esta razón como 2
sobre 5 podemos representar esta razón
como la fracción 2 sobre 5 y cuando
usamos esta anotación de fracciones
debemos entender lo que esto representa
esto nos está diciendo que dos quintos
de las frutas son manzanas y lo voy a
escribir así dos quintos de la fruta son
manzanas
una vez más esta es otra manera de
representar las razones podemos decir
que la razón de manzanas en relación con
el número de frutas es 25 y escribirlo
como aquí usando dos puntos o como 25 o
también podemos decir que es dos quintos
como una fracción pero también esta
anotación de fracciones se puede leer
como 2 a 5 en un contexto de razones
esta oración se puede leer como dos
quintos de la fruta son manzanas